Saludos Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
France 24 nuestro invitado de hoy es
James stottenberg secretario general de
la otan quien nos acompaña desde
Bruselas Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros muchas gracias a ustedes por
invitarme la semana pasada Ucrania atacó
objetivos militares muy adentro del
territorio Ruso y también hemos oído que
Estados Unidos está cada vez más
dispuesto a darle a kiev armas de mayor
alcance Así que una pregunta muy
sencilla teme que el conflicto esté
escalando ahora mismo la guerra en
Ucrania podría convertirse en una guerra
más amplia
la otan y sus aliados tienen dos tareas
principales respecto a la guerra en
Ucrania una es apoyar a Ucrania y
estamos prestando un apoyo sin
precedentes la otra tarea es evitar la
escalada de la guerra más allá de
Ucrania y lo hacemos en parte dejando
Claro que no somos parte en el conflicto
no tenemos tropas de la otan sobre el
terreno no tenemos aviones de la otan en
el espacio aéreo ucraniano pero estamos
apoyando Ucrania en su derecho a
defenderse un derecho de autodefensa que
está consagrado en la carta de las
Naciones Unidas También estamos
previniendo una escalada más allá de
Ucrania aumentando nuestra presencia en
la parte oriental de la alianza por lo
que tenemos más tropas de la otan
tenemos más barcos y aviones en la parte
oriental de la alianza ahora más que en
cualquier otro momento desde la Guerra
Fría para enviarle un mensaje claro a
Moscú de que un ataque directo a un
Aliado provocará una respuesta de todos
los aliados y lo hacemos no para
provocar un conflicto
para prevenir un conflicto para
presionar por la paz Así que estamos muy
centrados en evitar una escalada de la
guerra
Pero sabemos que el presidente ruso
declaró que suministrar misiles de largo
alcance sería cruzar una línea está a
favor de suministrar a Ucrania este tipo
de armas de largo alcance Ucrania lo ha
estado pidiendo y parece que Washington
se lo está planteando ahora está usted a
favor de esta medida
en primer lugar ya le hemos
proporcionado muchas armas avanzadas
como las y Marx que son armas de
precisión de largo alcance también hemos
suministrado Ucrania otros tipos de
sistemas avanzados de armamento
evaluamos constantemente Qué tipo de
sistemas hay que proporcionar a Ucrania
pero permítanme decir también que creo
que no sólo debemos centrarnos en nuevos
sistemas sino también en asegurarnos de
que los sistemas que ya están allá
funcionen
que funcionen como deberían esto
significa que debemos garantizar un
flujo constante de munición
piezas de repuesto y mantenimiento de
los sistemas existentes
piezas de artillería o buses defensa
antiaérea y Marx También tenemos
vehículos armados
tenemos sistemas de defensa aérea
todos estos sistemas que están en
Ucrania tienen que funcionar como es
debido Y eso requiere muchos suministros
de munición piezas de repuesto y
mantenimiento pero no descarta entregar
esas armas de las que acabamos de hablar
bueno como dije antes ya hemos entregado
por ejemplo y Marx pero no entraré en
sistemas específicos ese es un diálogo
que se mantiene constantemente entre los
aliados de La otan Los Socios Y por
supuesto con Ucrania
Vladimir Putin dijo que el peligro de
una guerra nuclear iban aumento está de
acuerdo con él
le hemos dejado muy claro al presidente
Putin a Moscú
que cualquier uso de armas nucleares en
Ucrania tendrá graves consecuencias para
Rusia
consecuencias dramáticas para Rusia
que no se puede ganar una guerra nuclear
y que nunca se debe librar
y estamos vigilando muy de cerca las
acciones de Rusia hasta ahora no hemos
visto ningún cambio en su postura
nuclear que requiera cambios por nuestra
parte pero seguimos atentos y vigilamos
de cerca lo que hace Rusia
la probabilidad de que Rusia utilice
armas nucleares en Ucrania sigue siendo
baja pero las consecuencias potenciales
son enormes por tanto el riesgo es algo
que tenemos que tomarnos en serio y eso
es exactamente lo que están haciendo los
aliados de La otan además La retórica
nuclear del presidente Putin sus
referencias al uso potencial de armas
nucleares es en sí misma prudente y
peligrosa
el presidente francés Emanuel Mako dijo
recientemente que los países
occidentales tenían que darle garantías
de seguridad a Rusia el día que vuelva
la mesa de negociaciones y dijo que uno
de los puntos esenciales que debemos
abordar es el temor de que la otan
llegue directamente a las puertas de
Rusia esto creó una furiosa reacción en
Europa del este en Ucrania está usted de
acuerdo con el presidente francés en que
habrá que darle esas garantías de
seguridad a Rusia o no es el momento de
hablar de eso
la tarea más inmediata e importante en
este momento es apoyar ahora para
garantizar que sean capaces de
prevalecer y sobrevivir como una nación
democrática independiente y soberana en
Europa
después creo que en algún momento esta
guerra terminará en la mesa de
negociaciones Pero lo que sí sabemos es
que lo que ocurra en esa mesa de
negociaciones está inextricablemente
ligado a la situación en el campo de
batalla
por tanto Si queremos que Ucrania
sobreviva que siga siendo una nación
democrática independiente y soberana en
Europa debemos apoyar a Ucrania
Esa es la mejor manera de lograr una paz
duradera garantizando que Ucrania sea
fuerte para que puedan lograr una
solución aceptable en la mesa de
negociaciones tiene que ser Ucrania la
Que decida Cuándo es el momento adecuado
y cuáles son las condiciones aceptables
para un acuerdo de paz
y también el presidente macron dijo
claramente que es Ucrania
la que decide el momento y las
condiciones para un acuerdo de paz
me preocupa que la estrategia rusa de
atacar las infraestructuras energéticas
de Ucrania este funcionando
es una forma de convertir en arma el
invierno
de privar a los civiles al pueblo
ucraniano de agua de luz de comer
el invierno llegó y es una forma brutal
de guerra porque está dirigida a
millones de civiles al mismo tiempo
pienso que los ucranianos no se
doblegarán de que seguirán defendiendo
su país su libertad
la protección de su derecho a existir
como nación soberana en Europa
Quiero entrar en la cuestión de Suecia y
Finlandia el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinken dijo la
semana pasada que confiaba en que pronto
entrarían en la otan sabemos que hay un
bloqueo por parte de Turquía
especialmente Turquía que exige la
extradición por parte de esos dos países
de personas supuestamente vinculadas al
pkk o de Los Seguidores del predicador
exiliado fetula
es usted también optimista en cuanto a
que esto se resolverá muy pronto
Confío en que todos los aliados
incluidos Turquía y Hungría que son dos
aliados nuestros que hasta ahora no han
ratificado los protocolos de adhesión lo
hagan no especularía sobre cuándo
exactamente pero Confío en que ocurrirá
entre otras cosas porque tenemos que
recordar que esta importante decisión se
tomó cuando todos los líderes de la otan
se reunieron en Madrid en la Cumbre de
la otan de junio del año pasado todos
los líderes de la otan incluido Turquía
decidieron entonces invitar a Finlandia
y Suecia a convertirse en aliados de La
otan los 30 aliados de La otan también
firmaron los protocolos de adhesión y
hasta la fecha 28 de los 30 aliados ya
han ratificado dichos protocolos de
adhesión en sus parlamentos nacionales
hasta ahora Este ha sido uno de los
procesos de adhesión más rápidos de la
historia de la otan tenemos que recordar
que Finlandia y Suecia presentaron su
solicitud en mayo y en junio ya los
estábamos invitando y firmando los
protocolos de adhesión permí Añadir
también que Finlandia y Suecia se
encuentran ahora en un lugar totalmente
distinto al que ocupaban antes de
presentar su solicitud tenemos más
presencia de la otan en la región
Contamos con garantías bilaterales de
seguridad de Estados Unidos Francia
Alemania Reino Unido y otros tenemos a
Finlandia y Suecia como invitados porque
se firmaron los protocolos de adhesión
Así que participan en las actividades
civiles militares de la otan En las
reuniones de cooperación por lo tanto es
inconcebible que si hubiera algún ataque
o presión de Rusia sobre Finlandia y
Suecia la otan no reaccionara hemos
recorrido un largo camino estoy seguro
de que también contaremos con la
ratificación de nuestros dos aliados
pero ahora estamos en un lugar muy
diferente al que ocupábamos antes de que
Finlandia y Suecia presentaran su
solicitud Espera que esto ocurra dentro
de unas semanas una vez más No estoy
especulando sobre el tiempo sino
diciendo que hemos tomado decisiones
importantes y que es una decisión
histórica para todos los aliados invitar
a Finlandia y Suecia todos los aliados
firmaron los protocolos de adhesión y
Finlandia y Suecia ya participan en las
actividades civiles y militares de la
otan Una última pregunta las tensiones
están aumentando en kosovo el Primer
Ministro de kosovo le pidió a las tropas
de mantenimiento de paz de la otan que
intervinieran mientras que el presidente
serbio dijo que le pediría la otan que
permitiera hacer vía desplegar militares
y policías en kosovo le preocupan los
últimos sucesos de kosovo la otan está
muy atenta a lo que sucede en kosovo en
los balcanes occidentales tenemos una
larga historia allá ayudamos a poner fin
a las dos Guerras étnicas en Bosnia
herzegovina y luego más tarde en kosovo
Serbia Y por supuesto todavía tenemos
nuestra presencia cuentan con la fuerza
caforce de la otan cerca de 4.000
efectivos han desempeñado un papel clave
en la estabilización de esa situación
nuestras fuerzas son capaces
preparadas vigilantes siguen la
situación muy de cerca la otan y la
Unión Europea están colaborando
estrechamente y mi mensaje a todas las
partes implicadas Es que se abstengan de
una retórica de escalada de una retórica
y unas acciones provocadoras y que
contribuyan a reducir las tensiones en
kosovo James stoltenberg quiero
agradecerle por haber estado en la
entrevista de France 24 y gracias a
todos por verla
[Música]